let's say i run some type of a factory
and i've studied my operations and i'm
able to figure out how my cost varies as
a function of quantity over a week on a
weekly period
and so to visualize that
let me draw it draw this cost function
so this is my cost axis
this right over here could be my
quantity axis
so that's quantity or q
my q ax let me just call that q
that's my q axis and my function might
look something like this
my function might look something like
this
it seems reasonable to me even if i
produce nothing i still have fixed costs
i have to pay rent on the factory i have
to probably pay people even if we
produce nothing and so let's say that
fixed cost in the week is one thousand
one thousand dollars and then as my
quantity increases so do my cost so
if i produce 100 units right over here
then my cost
goes up to thirteen hundred
thirteen hundred if i produce more than
that you see my costs increase and they
increase at an ever faster rate
now i go into a lot more
depth on things like cost functions in
the economics playlist but what i want
to think about in the calculus context
is what would the derivative of this
represent what would the derivative
of c with respect to q which could be
also written as c prime of q what does
that represent
well if we think about it visually
we know that we can think about the
derivative as the slope of the tangent
line so for example that's the tangent
line when q is equal to 100 so the slope
the slope of that tangent line is you
could view as c prime or it is c prime
of 100
but what is that slope telling us well
the slope is the slope is the change
this this is a change in our cost
divided by the change in our quantity
and it's the slope of the tangent line
we've this is what we first learned in
calculus as we get to smaller and
smaller and smaller changes in quantity
we essentially take the limit as our
change in quantity approaches zero
that's why we get that instantaneous
change so one way to think about it one
way to think about it is this is the
instantaneous this is the this is the
rate right on the margin at which our
cost is changing with respect to
quantity so if i were to produce just
another drop another atom of whatever
i'm producing how at what rate is my
cost going to increase and the reason
why i'm saying it right on the margin is
we see that it's not constant if our
cost function were a line it we would
have a constant slope the tangent line
would essentially be the cost function
but we see it changes right over here
our our the incremental
atom to produce here costs less than the
incremental atom right over here the
slope has slope has gone up and it might
make sense maybe i'm using some raw
material out there in the world and as i
use more and more of it it becomes more
and more scarce and so the market price
of it goes up and up and up but you
might say well why why are you even you
know why do i even care about the rate
at which my costs are increasing my the
rate at which my costs are increasing on
the margin which is why this is called
marginal
marginal cost
well the reason why you care about it is
you might try you might be trying to
figure out when do i stop producing
let's say this is orange juice if i know
that next gallon is going to cost me
five dollars to produce and i can sell
it for six dollars then i'm gonna do it
but if that next gallon if i'm up here
i've already produced a lot and i'm
taking all the oranges off the market
and now i have to transport oranges from
the other side of the planet or whatever
it might be and now that incremental of
gap incremental
gallon of oranges or
a gallon of orange juice cost me ten
dollars to produce and i'm not going to
be able to sell it for more than six
dollars it doesn't make sense for me to
produce it anymore so in a calculus
context or i guess you say in an
economics contest context if you can
model your
model your cost as a function of
quantity the derivative of that is the
marginal cost it's the rate at which
costs are increasing for that
incremental for that incremental unit
and there's other there's other similar
ideas if we had if we modeled our profit
as a function of quantity if we took the
derivative that would be our marginal
profit if we modeled revenue that would
be our marginal revenue how much is the
function increasing on the margin as or
how much does the function increase as
we increase our input as we increase our
quantity on the margin